The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK,
it's Laplace again today.
Laplace's equation.
And trying to describe--
That's a big area that's
a lot of people have
worked on for centuries.
And for the early
centuries, there
were always analysis methods.
And that's what we got
started on last time.
And we'll do a bit more.
There's no way we
could do everything
that people have worked
on years and years,
trying to find
ideas about solving.
But we can get the idea.
And this part, then,
is in the section
called Laplace's equation.
And the exam Wednesday
would include
some of these constructions.
So this is what we
did last time, we
identified a whole family of
solutions to Laplace's equation
as polynomials in x and y.
Of increasing degree n, and
then when we wrote them in polar
form they were fantastic.
r^n*cos(n*theta)
and r^n*sin(n*theta).
So my idea is just, we've
got them, now let's use them.
So how to use these solutions?
Because we can take
combinations of them,
we can create series
of sines and cosines.
So I'll do that first.
Series.
And then Green's function,
that's the name you remember,
we've seen it before.
That's the solution when the
right side is a delta function.
When we have Poisson's
equation with a delta there.
So that an important one.
And then well, a big part
of two-dimensional and
three-dimensional problems
is that the region itself,
not just the equation
but the region itself,
can be all over the place.
We'll solve when
the region is nice,
like a circle or a
square, and then there
is a way to, in principle,
to get other regions.
To change from a crazy region
to a circle or a square,
and then solve it there.
So that's called
conformal mapping.
And I can't let the whole
course go without saying
a word or two about that.
But somehow among
numerical methods,
it's conformal mapping--
There are packages
that do conformal mapping.
But they're not the
central way to solve
these equations numerically.
Finite differences,
finite elements are.
And that's what's
coming next week.
So this is the future; this
is the present, right there.
So, can I just start
with an example or two?
Like, how would you solve
Laplace's equation in a circle?
So, in a circle.
This is the idea here.
I have Laplace's equation.
OK, so I've got a
whole lot of solutions.
And I've even got chalk
to write them down.
OK, so here's my circle,
might as well make it
the unit circle.
Radius one.
And inside here is Laplace.
u_xx+u_yy=0.
No sources inside.
So we have to have
sources from somewhere,
and they will come
from the boundary.
So on the boundary,
we keep-- Let
me think of u as temperature.
So I set the temperature
on the boundary. u
equals some u_0,
some known function.
This is given.
This is the boundary condition.
This is the given
boundary condition.
And it's a function of-- I'm
going to use polar coordinates.
Polar coordinates are
natural for a circle.
So this is at r=1, so maybe
I should say on the boundary,
which is r=1, and going around
the angle theta, is given.
This is u_0(theta).
That's my given
boundary condition.
This problem is named
after Dirichlet,
because it's like giving
fixed conditions and not
Neumann conditions.
OK, so I'm just looking
for a combination.
For a function that
solves Laplace's equation
inside the circle, and
takes on some values
around the boundary.
And of course the
boundary values
might be plus one on the top
and minus one on the bottom.
Or the boundary condition
might vary around,
it might, variable
then come around.
But notice that this
is a periodic function.
This is 2pi-periodic, because
the problem's the same.
If I increase theta by 2pi I've
come back to the same point.
So it's got to have that value.
OK, so well let me give you
a couple of examples first.
Suppose u_0, suppose this
function-- Example 1, easy.
Suppose u_0 is sin(3theta).
So that means I've
got a region here,
I'm prescribing its
temperature on the boundary.
And I want to say what
does it look like inside?
And I'm prescribing right
now the sin(3theta),
so there theta is zero, so it's
zero, the boundary condition's
zero there, climbs to one, back
to zero, down to minus one.
back to zero.
Three times, and again comes
back to zero again there.
So, I'm looking for a solution
to Laplace's equation --
and I've got a
pretty good list --
that will match
u_0 when r is one.
So that's the
boundary, r is one.
So you can tell me what it is.
So you can solve this
problem, right away.
The answer is u of r and theta
is, what function will--?
Remember I've got
my eye on that list.
You too, right?
I'm just trying to get
one that when r is one
it will match sin(3theta).
What's the good guy?
It'll be on that list.
Which of those,
by itself, here I
don't need a series because I've
got such a neat u_0 function.
I'll get it right
with one answer,
and what is that answer?
I look there.
I say what do I do, so that at
r=1, I'll match sin(3theta).
I'll use r cubed sin(3theta).
So the good winner will
be r cubed sin(3theta).
That solves Laplace's equation.
We checked it out, it's the
imaginary part of x+iy cubed.
We could write it in x
and y coordinates if we
wanted but we don't want to.
And it matches when r is
one, it gives us sin(3theta).
That's it.
And of course I
could take any one.
Now suppose I'm trying
to match something that's
not as simple as sin(3theta).
In that case, I may
have to use all of them.
I mean, it's very, very
fluky that one term
is going to do it.
Usually, so my main
examples would be
I'll have to match all of them.
So what do I do?
At r=1, so my general solution
is a combination of these guys
I worked so hard to get.
The solution is of this form.
It's some a_0, the constant.
And then a_1*r*cos(theta),
and b_1*r*sin(theta).
And a_2 r squared cos(2theta).
And so on.
I'm just taking
any combination of,
I'm using the a's
as the coefficients
for the cosine guys.
And the b's, b_1, b_2, b_3
would be the coefficients
for the sine one.
OK, that's my general solution.
That solves Laplace's equation.
Every term did, so
every combination will.
Now, set r=1.
To match that r=1--
and match the boundary.
And match u_0(theta), the
required temperature around
the-- on the boundary.
The boundary being
where r is one.
So this is set r=1.
So then u_0(theta), this given
thing, has to match this,
when r is one.
So it's a_0 plus a_1, now what
do I write here? r is one,
so it's just cos(theta).
Now, b_1, r is one, so
I just have sin(theta).
And I have an a_2*cos(2theta),
and a b_2*sin(2theta),
and so on.
Here, just let me
put it together now.
I'm given any
temperature distribution
around the boundary.
It's in equilibrium,
the temperature,
where if the temperature's
high near that point
and low over here
the temperature
inside will gradually
go from that high point,
dot dot dot dot,
to the lower one.
By matching on the boundary.
And this is the match
on the boundary.
Now, this is really a lead in
to the last part of this course.
So whose name is associated
with a series like that?
Fourier.
You recognize that as what's
called a Fourier series.
So the idea is, I'm given
these boundary values.
I find their expansion
in sines and cosines,
and that's what
we'll do in November.
And then I've got it.
Then I know the a's and the b's.
And then basically I just put in
the r's. r and r squareds and r
cubeds and so on.
So then I've got
the answer inside.
In principle it's so easy.
So, why is it easy, though?
First, it's easy because it's
a circle we're working in.
If I was in an ellipse or
a strange shape, forget it.
I mean, so this
is quite special.
And secondly, it's easy because
these functions are so nice.
Fourier works with the
best functions ever.
These sines and cosines.
So I'll find a way to
find those coefficients,
the a's and the b's.
Even though there
are lots of them,
I'll be able to pick
them off one at the time,
the a's and b's.
Once I know the a's and
b's, I know the answer.
So do you see this is
in principle a great way
to solve it?
In fact, it's the way
we used over here,
when my u_0 was sin(3theta),
then the only term in its
Fourier series
was 1*sin(3theta).
And then the solution was
1 r cubed sin(3theta).
So you can learn
things from this.
For example, oh,
what can you learn?
One thing I noticed,
an important feature
of Laplace's equation is that
this solution inside the circle
gets very smooth.
The boundary conditions could
be like a delta function.
I could say that
on the boundary,
the temperature is zero
everywhere except at that
point it spikes.
So I could take u_0--
So example 2, and I
won't do it in full,
would be u_0 on the boundary
equal a delta function.
A spike at that one point.
So all the heat is coming from
the source at that one point.
Like I've got a
fire going there.
Keeping the rest of
the boundary frozen,
the heat's kind of
going to come inside.
So then how would I proceed?
Well, if I have this boundary
value as a delta function,
I look for its Fourier
series, and it's
a very important,
beautiful, Fourier
series for a delta function.
Would you want to know it?
I mean, we'll know
it well in November.
Would you want to
know it in October?
This is Halloween, I
guess, so delta-- I'll
tell you what it is.
Since you insist.
delta(theta) I think will--
I think there's a 1/(2pi)
or something.
Ah, shoot.
We'll get it exactly right.
It's something like 1 and 2
cos(theta) and 2cos(2theta),
I'm not sure about the 2pi.
2cos(2theta), and
2cos(3theta), and so on.
We'll know it well
when we get there.
What I notice about this delta
function-- Of course you're
going to expect the
delta function being
somehow a little bit strange.
At theta=0, what does
that series add up to?
Just so you begin to get
a hang of Fourier series.
At theta=0, what does
that series look like?
Well, all these
cosine thetas are?
One.
So this series at
theta=0 is 1+2+2+2+2...
It's infinite.
And that's what we want.
The delta function is
infinite at theta=0.
And it's periodic, of course,
so that if I go around
to theta=2pi I'll come
back to zero again.
At theta=pi, you could
sort of see, well, yeah,
theta=pi is a sort
of interesting point.
At theta is pi,
what's the cosine?
Is negative one, right?
But then the cos(2pi)
will be plus one.
So at theta=pi, I think I'm
getting a one minus a two plus
a two, minus a two, plus a two.
You see, it's doing its best to
cancel itself out and give me
the zero that I want, the
theta=pi over on the left side
of the circle.
Anyway, so that's
an extreme example.
But now, what's the
temperature inside?
Can you just follow
the same rule?
What will be the
temperature inside?
If that's the delta
function, if that's
the right series, whatever,
it might be a 4pi,
I'm not sure, for that.
Now, you can tell me
what's the solution, what's
the temperature distribution
inside a circle when
one point on the boundary has a
heat source, a delta function.
What do I do?
How do I match
this with this guy?
I just put in the r's, right?
If this is what it's supposed
to match when r is one,
then when r is-- So maybe
I'll put it under here.
So the u(r,theta),
from the delta guy,
is just put in the r's.
1+2r*cos(theta), and 2 r
squared cos(2theta), and so on.
OK, and eventually 2 r to the
100th cos(100theta), and more.
OK, I write this out, you could
say why did he write this down?
I wanted to make this point
that the important feature
of the solution to
Laplace's equation
is how smooth it gets when
you go inside the region.
And why is that?
Because at r=1/2, this term
is practically gone, right?
If I go halfway into the circle,
this term is practically gone.
1/2 to the hundredth power.
And if I go to the center of the
circle, it's completely gone.
In fact, what's the value
at the center of the circle?
What's the temperature
at the center?
1/2pi.
This is the only term
that's remaining.
And it's the average,
around the circle.
That makes physical
sense, I guess.
Since the whole thing's
completely isotropic,
we've got a perfect
circle, the value
at the center of
the circle is always
the average going around.
The constant term in the
Fourier series, this guy.
We'll get to know
that one very well.
That's the average.
You're just seeing a little bit
of Fourier series early, here.
But my point is that you
could have high oscillation
around the boundary,
that damps out
because of these powers of r.
And inside the circle it's
only the low order terms
that begin to take over.
This is the kind of
trick you have, or not
trick but the kind
of method that you
can use for solving Laplace's
equation by an infinite series.
Of course, a person
who wants a number
can complain that,
wait a minute,
how do I use that
infinite series?
Well, of course, if you
wanted to know the temperature
at a particular point
you'd have to plug in
that value of r,
that value of theta,
add up the terms until you
hope that they become so
small that you can ignore them.
So infinite series is
one form of a solution.
And somehow these are examples--
I should use the words
separation of variables.
Separation of variables
is the golden idea
in this analysis stuff.
Separation of variables means
I got the r part separated
from the theta part.
And that worked great,
worked well for a circle.
Let's see, maybe for a square I
could try to separate x from y.
Maybe there's a homework
problem, a solution that
separates x from y, I think
is something like-- So this
would be another family.
Good for squares, something
like sin(kx) sinh times,
so this separation is something
in x times something in y.
Again I'm just
mentioning things.
I think that that solves
Laplace's equation
because if I take
two x derivatives,
that'll bring down k squared,
but it'll flip the sign, right?
These two derivatives of
the sine will be a minus.
And if I take-- I
need a ky there.
And if I took two derivatives
of this hyperbolic sine,
you remember that's the
e^(ky) and the e^(-ky).
The two derivatives
of that will bring out
a k squared with a plus sign.
So two x derivatives bring
out the minus k squared,
two y derivatives bring
out a plus k squared
and together that solves
Laplace's equation.
We'll check that in
our homework problem.
So there would be an
example, good for a square.
So, there's hope to do an exact
solution in a special region.
Now, what's this
Green's function idea?
OK, that's now this
is another thing.
So last time we appreciated
that this combination x+iy was
magic.
The idea was that we could
take any function of x+iy,
and it solves
Laplace's equation.
Can we just see, sort of
very crudely why that is?
We saw the pattern, we
saw x+iy to the nth.
Sort of, we went as far as
n=3, checked it all out.
But now, really if I want to
be able to-- why does that
solve Laplace's
equation for any n?
Should I just plug that
into Laplace's equation?
What happens if I take the two
x derivatives of this thing?
So this going to be a
typical function of x+iy,
typically nice one.
If I take two x
derivatives, I want
to plug it in and
see that it really
does solve Laplace's equation.
So two x derivatives of
that will give me what?
The first x derivative
will bring down an n
times this thing to the n-1.
And then the next x derivative
will bring down an n-1 times
this thing to the n-2.
So that'll be the u_xx.
And what about u_yy?
This is my u.
I'm sort of just checking
that yes, this-- See again,
see if it still works Friday
what worked Wednesday.
That this x+iy is magic and
functions of it like powers,
exponentials,
logarithms, whatever,
all solve Laplace's equation.
OK, so we did u_xx,
and we got-- easy.
Now, what happens with u_yy?
Do you see the point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Sorry opposite sign.
And why does the sign
come out opposite?
Because of that guy.
Yeah, it's the
chain rule, right?
The derivative of
this with respect to y
will give me an n times this
thing to one lower power.
Times the derivative
of what's inside.
And the derivative of
what's inside is an i.
And then the second
derivative will bring down
an n-1, this guy will be down
to n-2, another i will come out
and-- Just what you want, right?
Because the i squared is
minus one, those cancel.
When those are equal
opposite signs.
And we get u_xx+u_yy equaling 0.
So that works.
And, actually, the same idea
would work for any function
of x+iy.
The two x derivatives
just give f''.
Two y derivatives will give f''
but the chain rule will bring
out i both times
and we've got it.
OK, I think we just need
another couple of examples.
And this of course could
be in polar coordinates,
f of re^(i*theta).
That's just, everybody
recognizes re^(i*theta) is
the same as x+iy?
Better just be sure
we've got that. x is
some point here in the complex
plane. iy takes us up to here.
So there's x+iy.
That's x+iy there,
but it's also--
So let me put those in better.
So there's x and there's y.
Everybody knows
this picture, right?
This x and this y, now if I
want to go to polar coordinates,
that angle is theta,
this x is r*cos(theta),
this y is r*sin(theta), and
this guy is re^(i*theta).
re^(i*theta).
r*cos(theta) plus i*r*sin(theta)
is the same as re^i*theta.
That's utterly fundamental.
Everybody's responsible
for that picture
of putting the complex numbers
into their beautiful polar
form.
That's what made our r to the
nth cos(n*theta) all so simple.
Now, what was I aiming to do?
Give a particular f.
Now I want to give a
particular function f, or maybe
a couple of choices.
A couple of functions f, and
see that their real parts
and their imaginary parts
solve Laplace's equation.
Let me take first a one
that works completely.
Take the real part and
the imaginary part--
Let me take e^(x+iy).
It's a function of x+iy,
extremely nice function
of x+iy, and we can figure out
its real and imaginary parts,
and we get two solutions
to Laplace's equation.
The good way is to write this
thing as e^x times e^(iy).
And again we'll write it as
e^x times cos(y)+i*sin(y).
So now I can see
that the real part--
I can see what the
real part is, and I can
see what the imaginary part is.
The real part will
be, that's real.
And that's real. so this
will so give me e^x*cos(y).
And the imaginary part
will be e^x*sin(y).
You see it.
And those will solve
Laplace's equation.
Can I give a name to this
whole field of analysis?
This e^z is an analytic -- I
should just use that word --
an analytic function.
And these guys, the real
and imaginary parts,
are two harmonic functions.
Maybe it's not so important
to know the word harmonic
function.
But analytic function,
yeah, I would
say that's an important word.
Actually, what does it mean?
It's a function of z.
So we're in the
complex plane here now.
It's a function of z, e^z, and
it can be written as a power
series, of course, one plus
z plus 1 over 2 factorial z
squared and all those guys.
So it has a power series.
That makes it a combination
of our special ones.
The great thing about that
series is it converges.
So an analytic function,
an analytic function
is the sum of a power
series that converges.
And this one does.
So there's an example.
Yeah, so the whole theory
of analytic functions
is actually, that's
Chapter 5 of the textbook.
And we won't get beyond this
point, I think, in one semester
with analytic functions.
So what am I saying, though?
I'm saying that the theory
of analytic functions
is closely tied to
Laplace's equation.
Because the real and
the imaginary parts
give me this pair u and s that
satisfy, they each satisfy
Laplace's equation.
And they're connected by the
Cauchy-Riemann equations.
Boy, it's a lot of mathematics
coming real fast here.
Now I'd like to take
one more example.
Instead of the exponential,
can we take the logarithm.
I want to take the log of x+iy,
and I want you to split it
into its real and
imaginary parts,
and get the u and the
s that go with that.
So this was like
the nicest possible.
We got a series of, e^z
is good for every z,
the series converges, fantastic.
It's an analytic
function everywhere.
Best possible.
Now we go to one that's not
best possible but nevertheless
highly valuable.
OK, so e^z, I've done.
Let me erase e^z, take log z.
OK, so now I'm not
doing e^z any more.
And I want to find
the logarithm, OK.
So, what's the deal
with the logarithm?
Real and imaginary parts.
Now I'm going to
take the log of x+iy.
That is a function of x+iy,
except at one point it has
a problem, right?
There's a point where this
is not going to be analytic,
and there's going to be a
special point in the flow which
is singular somehow.
But away from that point, we
have a nice-looking function,
the logarithm of x+iy, and
now I'd like to get its real
and imaginary parts.
I'd like to know
the u and the s.
But nobody in their
right mind wants
to take the logarithm
of a sum, right?
That's a very foolish thing to
try to do, the log of a sum.
What's the good way to
get somewhere with this?
Real and imaginary part.
I can take the log of a product.
So the polar is
way better again.
I want to write this as
a log of r e to the-- I
want to write it that way.
And now what's the
log of a product?
The sum of the two pieces.
So I have log r, and the log
of e^(i*theta), which is?
Which is i*theta.
Boy, look, this is fantastic.
Fantastic except at zero.
I mean, it's fantastic but
it's got a big problem at zero.
But it's an extremely
important example.
So what's the real part?
It's sitting there.
This is my u.
This is my u(r,theta), my
u(x,y), whatever you want,
is the log of r.
The log of the square root
of x squared plus y squared.
I claim that again by this
magic combination, this log,
this-- r is the square root
of x squared plus y squared.
I claim if you substitute
that into Laplace's equation
you get zero.
It works.
And what's the
imaginary part, the s?
The twin is the imaginary
part, which is theta.
Oh, what is theta in x,
if I wanted it in x and y?
What would theta be?
It's the arctan,
it's the angle whose
tangent is something. y/x,
so if I really want it
in rectangular xy stuff, it's
the angle whose tangent is y/x.
And again, if you
remember in calculus
how to take derivatives
of this thing
and you plug it into Laplace's
equation you get zero.
It works.
So that's a great
solution except where?
At zero.
Except at zero.
And this doesn't tell us
what's happening at zero.
It's an excellent solution.
What's the picture?
So by Wednesday's
exam I'm not expecting
you to be an expert on the
theory of analytic functions.
I don't expect you to know
any conformal mappings.
By Wednesday, God, that's-- But,
I do expect you to have these
pictures in mind.
So when I draw those
axes, what picture is it
that I'm planning on?
I'm planning on the
equipotentials u
equal constant, and the,
who are the other guys?
The streamlines.
The places where the
stream functions-- So here
is the potential function.
So what are the
equipotential curves?
For that guy?
Circles.
This is a constant
when r is a constant,
so the equipotential
functions would be circles.
I don't want to draw that
circle with radius zero, though.
I'm nervous about that one.
But all the others are great.
And what are the
streamlines, now?
The streamlines are, well,
what will the streamlines be?
If I've drawn one family, you
can tell me the other family.
The streamlines will be?
Radial lines.
Because they're going to
be perpendicular to this.
And so what do I get, this is
the stream function, theta.
So what's a streamline?
The stream function
should be a constant.
Theta's a constant.
That means I'm
going out on rays.
Those are all streamlines.
Again, everything fantastic.
If you look in a
little region here
you see just a beautiful
picture of equipotentials
and streamlines crossing
them at right angles.
Everything great.
Just that point is
obviously a problem.
Now, and I'm suspecting
that there's a source here.
I think this flow, which
is given by these guys,
comes from some kind of a
delta function right there.
And the flow goes outwards.
So I know u, I know v is
the gradient of u, right?
I could take the x
and y derivatives,
I'd know the velocity.
I know the stream function,
the divergence would be zero.
Everything great,
except at the origin.
I think we've got some
action at the origin.
Because, here's
the way to test it.
I want to see what's
happening at the origin.
And I'm going to use
the divergence theorem.
Yeah.
I'm going to use the
divergence theorem.
So the divergence theorem says--
What is the divergence theorem?
So this is the key thing that
connects double integrals.
Let me take a circle
of radius R. So
that's the circle of radius
R. R could be big, or little.
So I integrate
over the circle of
radius R. So what's the
deal? v is the same as w.
What does the divergence
theorem tell me?
It tells me that if I
integrate, what do I integrate,
the divergence of w?
dx/dy, or r*dr*d theta.
Then I get the flux.
So this is a key identity.
Fundamentally, more than
just the key identity,
it's central here.
The total flow out of
the region must make it
through the boundary.
So I integrate this
boundary, and this boundary
is a circle of radius
R, and what do I
integrate along that circle?
What's the other side of
the divergence theorem?
w dot n. w dot n,
around the boundary.
And remember, I have
this nice-- my curve here
is this nice circle.
So I'm going to integrate
around that circle.
First of all, what is n?
By definition, n is the
normal that points outward,
straight out.
So it's actually
going out that way.
At every point it's
pointing straight out.
And ds-- Yeah, I think
we can figure out exactly
what that right-hand side is.
How do I get that
right-hand side?
I'm looking for w, and
then I have to integrate.
OK, here is my u.
My u is log r.
So what's the gradient of log r?
It points outwards.
And how large is the derivative?
So the derivative of
this log r is 1/r.
I think that this comes down
to, this is the integral.
Around the circle.
I think that this thing is 1/R.
I went pretty quickly there,
so I'll ask you to
look in the book
because this is such an
important example it's
done there in more detail.
So I'm claiming that
the derivative is 1/R,
and that it points directly out.
So the gradient points out.
The normal points out, so that
I just get exactly 1/R. Now,
what is ds?
For integrating
around the circle
what's a little tiny
piece of arc on a circle?
Of radius R?
R d theta.
Good man.
Now that's an integral
I can do, right?
And what do I get?
2 pi.
R cancels R, I'm integrating d
theta around from zero to 2pi.
The answer is 2pi.
So what do I learn from that?
I learn that somehow this source
in the inside has strength 2pi.
What's sitting in there is
2pi times a delta function.
This is the solution
to Laplace's equation
except at that source
term, so I really
should say Poisson's equation.
This has turned out
to be the solution
to Poisson with a delta,
or with 2pi times a delta.
We have just solved
this important equation.
Poisson's equation
with a point source.
And, of course, that's
important because when
you can solve with
a point source,
you can put together
all sorts of sources.
And this is called
the Green's function.
The Green's function
is the solution
when the source is a delta.
So if I divide by
2pi, now I've got it.
I divide this by 2pi and
there is the Green's function.
I have to put that
in bold letters.
Green's function.
It's the solution
to the equation when
the source is a
delta and the answer
is u is the log of r over 2pi.
So that's the Green's
function in 2-D. Physicists,
you know, they live and die
with these Green's function.
Live, let's say, with
Green's function.
And they would want to know
the Green's function in 3-D.
So the Green's function
in three dimensions
also turns out beautifully.
This is in, they would
say, in free space.
This is the Green's function
when there's no other charges.
Nothing is happening, except for
the charge right at the center.
And if I'm in two dimensions the
Green's function is this log r.
So it grows more slowly.
It behaves like log r.
And in 3-D I think the
answer is 1/(4pi*r).
It's just amazing that
those Green's functions,
when the right side is a
delta, have such nice formulas.
OK, let me take one moment here.
I'll tell you what
conformal mapping is about.
But what's your take-home
from this lecture?
Your take-home is two
methods that we can really
use to get a formula
for the answer.
One method was for Laplace's
equation in a circle.
Get the boundary conditions in
a series of sines and cosines,
and then just put in
the r's that we need.
That's a simple, simple method.
Provided we can get started
with the Fourier series.
The second method is,
look at functions of x+iy,
and try to pick one that
matches your problem.
And if your problem has a
point source, at the origin,
we found the one.
So the literature
for hundreds of years
is aimed at solving
other problems.
If the point source is
somewhere else, what happens?
That's not hard.
If it's not a point source
but some other kind of source,
or if the region
is not a circle.
Can I say in one final
sentence just what to do,
this conformal mapping
idea, when the region is not
a circle.
Well, I can say it in one
word, make it a circle.
I mean, that's what Riemann
said, you could do it.
You could think of a
function, so Riemann said that
there's always some
function of x+iy,
let me call this Riemann's
function capital F of x, y.
So this is now the idea
of conformal mapping.
Change variables.
Conformal mapping is
a change of variables.
He picked some function and
let its real part be X and let
its imaginary part
be Y. Capital Y. OK,
this is totally ridiculous
to put conformal mapping
in 30 seconds.
But, never mind,
let's just do it.
The book describes
conformal mappings
and classical applied
math courses do much more
with conformal mapping.
But the truth is,
computationally
they're not anything like
as much used as these.
So what's the idea?
The idea is to find a
neat function of x+iy,
so that your crazy
boundary becomes a circle.
In the capital X,
capital Y variables.
So you're mapping
the region, ellipse,
whatever it looks like,
by changing from little x,
little y, where it was an
ellipse, to capital X, capital
Y, where it's a circle.
And the point is
Laplace's equation
stays Laplace's equation.
That change of variables does
not mess up Laplace's equation.
So that then you've
got it in a circle.
You solve it in a
circle, for these guys.
And then you go back.
In a word, you're able to solve
Laplace's equation in this
crazy region because you
never leave the magic x+iy.
You find a combination with
that magic x+iy that makes
your region into a circle.
In the circle we now know how
to use capital X plus i capital
Y. You're staying with
that magic combination
and getting the region
to be what you like.
So people know a lot of
these conformal mappings.
A famous one is
the Joukowski one,
that takes something that
looks very like an airfoil,
and you can get a
circle out of it.
So I'll put down
Joukowski's name.
So that's one that I trust
Course 16 still finds valuable.
It's a transformation
that takes certain shapes
and they include shapes
that look like airfoils,
and produce circles.
OK, so sorry about such a
quick presentation of such a
basic subject.
Conformal mapping, not on any
exam, that'd be impossible.
It's really this stuff that
you're number one responsible
for.